a pair of tourists drove their car into
a harbor after mistakenly following GPS
direction what are you doing David I'm
following the directions I could see
that would happen in my
marriage hey toes welcome to another
episode of Dum people Town population
you population Hubble everybody I was
going to say population Hubble yub it's
Rob just for I'm so happy here it's nice
to be back in the dumb world before when
I did this I think I wasn't here I was
in my home and it was
maybe it's just take our shirts off and
just relax you emotionally let's just
put on the lotion what uh the I ran into
Rob in the wild and it was it was Rob in
the wild fantastic was I with by myself
or with byself what where what set it at
a golf driving range yeah it's was like
the woods yeah no it wasn't in the wild
per se he wasn't like eating from the
carcass of an animal yeah we were a
driving we were very at a very exclusive
public driving range and you were by
yourself I was by myself cuz I think I
had like a few minutes and I'm like let
me drive by here and I while I was going
to pick up my kid from school or
something I'm like I'm going to work on
something and then he came by and said
hi and I'm like all right we need you
back on the podcast here we are do so if
you have kids do you ever see
somebody who uh do you ever do this or
do you ever do this Dan you're not
participa in this but you see
someone they see you doing the same
thing and you're not with your kids but
they're with their kids so you feel like
you're a dead be dad cuz every time they
see like every time somebody I have one
guy in my neighborhood is always with
his kid and then he sees me and I'm just
walking by myself it looks like I'm
neglecting my family completely cuz
every time he sees me I'm by myself like
I never do anything with my kids I mean
it depends on what you're doing like if
you know if you're in like a jerking off
in like a Safeway parking lot say how's
the separation going great working it
out yeah you got your place sleeping
here it's very comfy behind the dumpster
nobody make a thing all right so I like
to watch him gather the cart just get
anyway world's getting dumber and we get
story sent in by our fans the world is
getting really dumb right really dumb
really really fast I think it's
homeschooling I do think it's h I think
homeschooling has something I'm I was
just reading about how like
homeschooling is getting so hu I mean
this is an old story this is a different
podcast no no no no no it's not but it's
not helping but by the wayo
homeschooling is like a what was Zach
Galan A's joke about I went to my prom
it was homeschool it was homeschool
homeschooling is so homeschooling is
like a you just run a big risk a one
night stand that
essentially suddenly turns into like a
marriage in terms of what you I was
listening to
go I was listening to a podcast about a
cult where the cult the cult next door
and it was about the cult's leader was
this the leader of the family ran the
family like a cult and he wanted to
control the information that the kids
were getting and so he decided to pull
them out of school and homeschool them
and he did it for a year and was like I
can't do this [__] I got a cult to run I
can't this is too hard parenting harder
than the cult it's hard homeschooling is
so much wor than a cult wait nobody
wants so to me homeschooling is like if
you find like a really weird good diet
and you're like you got to eat like a
pound of Basil a day and only protein
and this and you'll lose weight and like
it works for a while but then if you do
it for like 9 years you're going to be
like oh [__] I don't have any iron in my
diet anymore and I don't have these
essential things part of comes out I get
like massive I sleep like 14 hours day
like I don't even know how did this what
is
this oh my God the detours we might as
well call this detour town it's not just
this episode all right so homeschooling
all right so it is getting dumber and so
I have a story sent in by our good
friend Derek Shipley who is one of our
fans who sends in stories I love Derek
up to these days he's sending in stories
he's a Stringer so Derek is uh we don't
know is this Derek's job so yeah sending
in bits to you is derck a lawyer wait am
I thinking of Derrick Lipkin Derrick
lipin is lawyer dere Shipley sends US
stories I don't listen to this podcast
this we got a host full of Derek that a
stable full of D you know who won't
listen to anymore Bo Derek Bo D will
will not listen to this podcast she
walked off one bad interview well she
ran off in slow motion in cornrow okay
two people will get that joke I give it
a
10 and both of them only know it from
Tom did you say I give that joke a 10 I
did get out of here all right get out of
here T here's the headline tourists in
Hawaii followed their GP didn't you do a
movie about Hawaii yes you did I did I I
was the star of the movie The descc I
was the star tourists in Hawaii follow
nominated you for that thank you okay
tourists in Hawaii followed their GPS
and drove their car straight into a
harbor pretty sure that was not supposed
to happen quote I don't know who's
giving that writing this well one of the
things did you you got shot in Kawaii
right um I think so yeah stop you don't
know I don't remember I don't think it
was kaai but I
and uh I love the island I love one of
the things I love about Hawaii
especially kauwaii is it's on you it it
it Hawaii hasn't been fully you know
kids safed like most of America has with
the Grand Canyon and stuff like that
there's plenty of areas where you go
where they're like this is how many
people died here and that's the trail go
ahead jum off the bridge they don't have
I don't think they have snakes in Hawaii
no there's almost no Predators it's like
some deer on some of the islands
especially Kawai it's is this podcast
sponsored by Hawaii why are we talking
about Haw working on it but I'm just
saying them driving there probably was
no signage like it was just like well
you're dumb enough to do what they do
their car just a PA of tourist drove
their car into a harbor after mistakenly
following GPS direction what are you
doing David I'm following the directions
it says go left on this
dock I could see that would happen in my
marriage I could see that happening you
would really okay is that okay you want
me to okay then I will I will are you
happy now we're in the ocean now we're
drowning now are you happy great did it
you will get into a principal argument
well I listened I listened I listened
and the water's coming like oh but don't
worry we can't roll the windows down
because you're
too in our car and I'm not making fun of
my wife but I am but in her car she has
those things those little hammers that
you use to smash out your window in case
you go into a lake you because the
pressure becomes too much so you have to
have a little thing but she has it still
in the packaging oh my God she'd have to
be like let me get this she can't get it
off trying to bite it and the water's
going God damn it all right the incident
happened on Saturday in in
hanaho uh small I am yeah I am that is
the actual it's almost is the native
pronunciation small booat Harbor in kyua
Kona a region on the west coast of
Hawaii Big Island now you are using the
correct a video and I'll show you the
video this a gz up Don hoose down that's
right a video by Christy Hutchinson a
witness to the incident shows the two
women buckled into their Dodge Caravan
just two women in a Dodge Caravan hey
this is their thmo and Louise guess
Louise and Thelma they just watched the
movie and they like got inspired while
it was headlights deep in the the murky
water now that to me sounds like a song
from Florida Georgia Line headlights
deep in the murky water oh headlights
deep in the mky water or Jacob Dy Dylan
headlight One One Headlight deep One
Headlight deep headlight deep in the
murky water said to the man I didn't
know that was your
daughter he brought it home he brought
it home he brought it home and so did
this hammer out Hammer her Windows
steing the package don't know what I'm
doing just a song about losing your
virginity all
floating I was sitting here I mean if
Bob Seager can sing sing about a teenage
girl's tits we can do whatever we want
now on Main Street I was sitting here
trying to seek Shelter From the rain and
then the next thing I saw a car drive
directly past our boat into the harbor
at a pretty decent speed Hutchinson told
the PO it was so confidently done they
didn't have a look of panic on their
face Elma they were still smiling oh my
God laughing and smile it was a rental I
mean that's when you don't really give
did you get coverage did you get the
coverage we don't need it we don't need
it my insurance c i I used an American
Express and they have insurance that's
my excuse all the time Hutchinson's
video on Sunday shows the car's
windshield wipers still moving as the
CLS slowly tipped forward but the women
did not appear to be panicking turning
on the wipers is such a great you got to
get rid of the
water your wipers don't have the
strength I mean that's a laurel and
Hearty right or that's like if someone
described us trying to continue to have
a career at this point in our lives so
like you're just turning on wipers as
you're going in the lake on this one you
really need to took us a second to
figure out what's going on because they
didn't seem panicked or have any sense
of urgency to get out of the car at what
point do you think this is like a prank
or someone's filming this for social
media they're on island time she was we
got it Island time we'll open the this
woman was already filming right she said
she in the video she just saw them go in
and then started filming I like the
witness was like the car drove by our
boat right yeah anytime a car if a car
drives by your boat and your boat's in
the water oh my God de this is better
than
snorkeling pretty sure that wasn't
supposed to happen Hutchinson said in
her video other Witnesses shouted at the
tourists to get out of the car so she's
on island time having fun watching this
and other people like get these people
out eventually the tourists unbuckled
themselves the passenger climbed out
through the window and waited out while
the driver sat on the window seemingly
Unsure how to escape video also showed
several men stepping in trying to save
the women you know like when guys you so
far these are two of the
dumbest ever very hot I bet Imaging them
being very h yeah well that's how many
men came to help yeah you know what I
mean n dudes jumping in we only need
it's like we only need two we got back
up here this is like the climax of an
80s TNA movie do you know what you're
supposed to do though in that situation
like when you know the car going down in
the car going down and your windows are
up do you know what you're supposed to
do let it fill and then open the door
yeah but how terrifying would that be to
let it you're supposed to crack the
windows if the if the power doesn't
always still work you're supposed to
crack the so it fills up you let it
[__] fill up with murky water and
then you're supposed to like swim out to
open the door and spin you won't be able
to open the door be pressure pressure to
so you're supposed to put the windows
down let the water rush in your kids are
screaming your dog is barking if it's a
harbor dead deer in the B you you don't
know there's a certain parts where you
could go off and you're going down 20 30
40 so you're also waiting for that where
you're like man I the video bottom it
we're going to find out where the bottom
is in this life life the video captured
the moment the car sank at the harbor
dipping in the water nose first then
disappearing beneath the surface the van
was later hauled out of the water by uh
tow Cru per Hawaii news now which is
where I get all my news by the way
Hawaii news Hai news now is pretty good
that's why your accent is so good your
pronunciation Hawaii news not out how do
you tow that out you got to be a crane
situ giant magnet and the amount of
[__] you're going to get from the
toe guy you know is like what you do
what' you do well look what you did here
you want me check the
tires you sure you know which way to go
home now okay yall have a good trip home
we're just going to make a left turn by
that do oh no we're not stupid we'll
drive over here on the road she added
that the she believed the tourists were
sisters but that she did not have any
other information about them however no
one was Hur in the incident and that at
what point do you think they were like I
don't think this is right well this is
the problem they seem to have never so
now you're going to hear this is again
their quotes there was a moment that I
read this and I'm like I kind of believe
them when on land the tourist said they
were on their way to a manta ray tour
and they're like I guess we're just
going to drive all the way to you got to
go all the way into the ocean one of
them it's like a safari it's a glass
bottom boat we were
homeschooled there there are Manta
companies directly on either side of the
ramp I can see how such a mistake could
happen in heavy rain perhaps is what she
said the wipers are on already because
it's raining night time no it's daytime
daytime that's I thought God samanth an
Information Specialist for Hawaii's
Department of Transportation told the
post that the occurrence was quote kind
of rare so it should be the most rare
thing were there mushrooms involved I
don't know I think if that was it then
I'd be like oh well that's what that
pilot you know Alaska Airlines oh yeah
he wanted to take the plan down but took
a bunch of mushrooms cuz he'd been
depressed and he and he' been up for
like 36 hours so do you think this woman
and I think people in Hawaii are have a
sense of humor and they have a healthy
disdain for all tourists that they're
idiots who are coming over here so this
is to this woman I'm sure said it with a
straight face but full irony Taris gave
advice for tourists in Hawaii telling
the post if you see a body of water
don't drive towards
it what do you mean what if you want to
go to the beach what are you supposed to
don't never go to the beach just don't
go that close
play the video you these addresses moved
this a podcast though how will people
see it we'll put Aaron will put the
video in YouTube but I'll just play it
for you guys hold on here we go ready
and who is this this is the women yeah
this is look at them they are hot
they're just too older right they're not
hot that is not even raining that hard
it's not even raining that hard you guys
it's barely oh they're they're like it
almost looks like they drove onto a ramp
they don't look at all concerned and it
doesn't seem dire they're not underwater
yet and the windows already down right
the wipers when you're in the ocean so
Dan what's that thing that's like the to
the duckboats in Boston oh yeah and the
wi there are some vehicles that are semi
amphibious there is it's like there's a
moment when a tsunami is coming I've
seen a bunch of these videos where it
seems like it's going to be fun for
going to be fun and then very quickly
it's not fun they are they do seem to be
at a a a ramp she's hang I they are but
like and they're trying to get them
before cuz it's going to drop off real
fast it's going to drop off real fast
yeah look at her sitting on the edge
sitting on the edge reverse it I can't
wait for people to see this get out is
that a Kia sento what kind of vehicle is
that I don't know but it is one I'd just
be standing on the dock being like did
you guys thought think you rented a boat
a car company should take the lead and
be like this thing floats so if you ever
drive in in the water you can get as
[__] up as you want don't worry
going to FL you can easily get out of
there with the help God I wish we could
interview uh so there you go and this
guy's like throwing a rope to that guy
Buddy's bring there look at this guy
just hanging out who talks about it you
they everybody is very chill so calm no
one time you're on Rob The Descendants
in the that's exactly Aloha drowning is
supposed to be a nice way to die I have
heard thank you for having the guts to
say that so do you think they went on
going windshield wiers did they go on
the manade tour or not did they get to
see one I don't know this they got to
see Nemo we're trying to find the manay
what's the difference between a manay
and a stingray just size a Mana Ray is
bigger are you guys biologists I mean we
are disgraced disgraced biologist he was
honorably discharge I was dis I was
dishonorably you know what if you do
homeschool you could do that to kids you
are now a biologist they have no idea
you give out
doctorates 3 months of doing home school
with your kids you're going to be like I
don't I too much I literally give a lot
of credit to the people who do it right
I mean the curriculum and I say curricul
who's doing it right there's got to be
some I don't know I bet you we know
people that we didn't know our
homeschooled and you'd be like no uh
well we wasn't Tim TBO homeschool maybe
I rest my Cas I rest my Cas no I I bet
there are people who do it right let me
and say there someone who is committed
to the full job or if you live in a
rural area where there is but for the
sake of our careers it's funnier for the
people who do it wrong right who kind of
have do it if you're a former college
professor and you're like you know what
I'll take it on I'll teach the whole
neighborhood bring them around every day
in my garage no M for no money be do
that for no money in tons of aggravation
you want me to watch your kids for you
sure I'll put up with hormones and kids
who don't want to do it let me do that
for nothing for I'll take the
aggravation on all right there you go
that's Story number one so many dumb
people so many dumb people Story number
one down the books we'll take a break
Jay's going to do Story number two we'll
find out what Dan's got going on and
we'll find out what we're what we have
all this stuff's coming up it's D people
Town Rob huel is our guest don't go
anywhere
around hey guys welcome back to the show
Rob Hu with us we're going to find out
what he's got going on but first let's
tell you what we have uh in the works
yeah so I think the next thing on the
books for us is uh this drops when I
think it's going to drop yeah we have a
tag it at The Comedy Store on uh
November 15th which is a Wednesday which
I believe is probably tomorrow night if
this drops on that I might just come
watch come please one of where we tag
our friends jokes yes uh we tag our
friends jokes it's super fun and then on
December 1st and 2nd we're at hilarities
in Cleveland right after after the new
year on the fourth we're in Portland on
the fifth we're in Seattle helium and
then the crocodile and then end end of
the month we're back in Denver at Comedy
Works South that's the beginning of
February and then Comedy Castle and then
Minneapolis and then Austin go out every
weekend every month every month once mon
okay so and you just blow off your
families and say sometimes they bring
them it's like scene in It's like the
scene in um Annie Hall which are we
allowed to
reference no no we're allowed to so
there's a moment in Annie Hall where
we're only gone like three or four days
out of the month but to go do stand up
for that and work but if you ask our
children we are dead beat dad SC in
whether's in therapy he's like how much
time how much sex are you having he's
like hardly any three to four times a
week then it's her therapist how much
sexx are you have and she's like all the
time three to four times a week and if
you ask your friends you guys are always
with your kids we're all you ask our
friends we're always with our kids you
ask our kids are like my dad I remember
him I think he's on the road he's a road
comic yeah so we do it but we love it
it's so it's certainly not for the money
cuz we have to split it but the joy of
doing it and the actual Act of it and
the building chance to meet the people
listen this podcast know you've done
you've done I'm jealous of of standups
I'm jealous of like just performing live
because the pandemic kind of took that
away from me a little bit so I'm
starting to get back more into it but um
yeah I I love that you're are you
popping up at things around town I mean
you know we do shows at Largo uh in town
and I haven't done anything at UCB
because UCB is now kind of a different
thing but I think I'm going to do some
stuff there um have you guys ever done
like a human giant reunion we have not
and I was thinking just because the
state is doing it right now you 100% sh
100% it's not I think it's just like I
don't know what aiz is doing you know I
mean I talked to him and and we're all
you know me and sheer see each other all
the time but aiz is sort of in and out
of this country and he's in England and
stuff like that and he's great but I
think he's you know he kind of does his
own thing and like so I don't know that
he would be down but we I've never asked
and who knows maybe not a tour but like
a show in New York would be freak or
like sketchfest is always great about
hosting stuff like
thatch this year we're going to go up
there you how how did this get made
there no we're going to do improv there
uh with this crew that we call dinosaur
now which just a bunch of old white guys
that's what we call a dinosaur
dinosur well how can people follow you
and know where to see you dude you know
whatever Instagram I don't give a [__]
don't follow me don't follow me I
challenge you I challenge you he defies
you to follow him I def you to follow on
threads Rob Hubble on Instagram and
threads there you go that's how I do it
Hubble on Truth you'll see me you'll see
me the driving range most people that's
how most people that's where I tell most
people at my shows driving you guys are
doing an improv driving R show um all
right well let's get into this story
called bottom I know should uh all right
this is sent in by our good buddy carlen
mcder she's the best she Caren that wow
she plugged herself better than I do she
don't follow H she encourages people to
follow don't follow Hubble reminder to
all our friends I we may be switching
this to threads we might all right
Daniel this you might know about and you
might have been involved in it all right
here's the headline dice roll settles
Tai in small Wisconsin Town election do
you Dice R my current hour has a huge
bit about Wisconsin that the fact that
nobody [__] even knows what's
happening in that state there's such you
guys joked about it when you did Comedy
on State the first time together I'm
tracking
iter no one knows you want to know what
happened in Ry ler true I'll just tell
you this please uh like 40 50 years ago
three drunk guys one night it might a
hundred years ago decided that they
wanted to create a monster for their
town and so they created what's called a
Hodag it's like a frog demon with horns
and it's become the entire identity of
this town they have one of the biggest
country music festivals in the country
called the Hodag Festival the Hodag
Festival godamn so they just got drunk
really one night and then created a
thing that became the town's whole
identity so that's what you can do in
Wisconsin so do you guys know what bise
is no no so Wisconsin every single bar
it happens in the dtas and stuff too but
B dice you go into a bar you will play
you can play for shots with the
bartender and and uh custody of your
kids that probably you do the shake you
can do the shake of the day that usually
is in like a you know those big PR like
clear pretzel containers yeah it's the
dice are in there and then you shake it
and then put it down and then they add
up your numbers the shake of the day
will win what's in the pot you pay like
a dollar to do the
shake every bar in Wisconsin I would say
say there's probably some bougie
[__] in you know Madison and
Milwaukee that don't do this but outside
of that everywhere okay and drinking
you've never been in a bar you're just
hearing people go bang it's just
throughout the whole
night I don't go you have you don't go I
don't go to yahoos been to yaho Yahoo's
up at the cabin yahoos is doing B ice
every s they do at the plaza for Plaza
Burg they do Shake of the day they'll do
Shake of the month and then your number
gets put up there and if you if you if
you're the winner for the ice settles a
lot of stuff in Wisconsin apparently ice
especially apparently now elections
elections I'm doing this story basically
so you said election election so this an
election solv by a you crazy [__] you
can work this in your act I talk about
bise then you're story story in and
we're doing this I literally might go do
you [__] know that where the audience
thinks I'm to once I tell them what the
drinking age is in Wisconsin there isn't
one and I'm not lying well all of that
[__] people just think I'm making it up
Wisconsin no you're going to add this to
list okay so I'm doing this basically so
Dan can do his Wisconsin accent
throughout the whole time and we all
right I'll do it go okay an election in
a small Wisconsin Town came down to a
roll of the dice one that wasn't stolen
hey okay right easy after Rob this is
the most Wisconsin name I'll yell it
back at you Rob zoski Rob
zoski now I bought a car here before and
I'm not getting screwed around like I
did we're at zki for you guys tried to
make me add cruise control and I'm not
paid for that [__] I like a window I
crank not press rob you showed up here
in a boat um damn right and I am trying
to leave in a buck your friend here Nate
Bell is did you mispronounce Rob Joi and
Nate Bell each received how many votes
to be president of the Sister Bay this
is D County this is D County Village Bo
of the village board yeah how many votes
sister
St how many votes did they receive I bet
I mean so it was a tie I bet there's
like 200 people in this town I bet they
got 100 votes each 100 each I'm going to
say 36 each
756 votes and it should have been seven
but I forgot to vote okay here it is get
your answers in you would have broken
the
tie voted in my mind I got I don't know
why you can't yell your vote I yell does
I went by said me on for
me I should be able to vote after did
you hear Rob Rob put in for himself all
right it they get your answers in they
each received 256 vs Rob president of
the Sister Bay Village board the race
went to a tie break Village clerk Heidi
T Heidi heid T oh she looks good she
looks good I remember her from high
school she had no work done she looks
good same haircuts at High School in I
like her with a little more meat on the
is she still dancing at the Foxhole y
she's still fox tail the fox tail doing
a couple of sh fo a strip club she's got
an artificial
hand and you know what it feels better
than her natural yeah she likes to use
that hand better it still has the
dexterity give her high five when I'm
drunk I don't even notice she's got a
posable
thumb it's mechan
an artificial hand that you could pick
up a coin with it and drop it in the old
juk box play a little Foreigner and I
got drunk on Blatz 2 years ago and I
said hey it's just me and you you know
I'm bartenders here but she she's asleep
and I said hey why you getting quiet Rob
Heidi I'm so sorry to hear about the
death of your husband I feel so bad can
I touch your
stump and she let me she un unscrewed
the hand I'm going to be honest that's
the hardest I've been in 10 years so now
you got a DH now you got a thing for
stum oh Heidi I hope they solve your
husband's murder no that's I'm doing an
Irish oh Heidi why is he smile why is
Nate Bell smiling about that when he say
that oh I hope they catch that s
say you're saying that whis colder than
lake wiona is that case I'll tell you
that told the candidates the election
would be settled via a game of chance
she just decided this Yep this what this
as per no she's like I've had enough all
right you I'm sick of all the bickering
and now we're going to settle this okay
now you get the bar dice this this is
where this is Wisconsin as per the state
election code stop Dan it's in the code
that it's a dice roll what I gave him a
chance all right what are they doing in
Wisconsin I won't say what the dice roll
was and who it was in favor of we can
guess that later God it has to be the it
has to be what's his name I don't know
drawn a lot of interest because it's
such an unusual thing Miss Ty told the
BBC the BBC is up in this story but on
the other that's a step down because you
I guarantee you in the 70s this was
televised yeah just local news movie TV
movie is just like what the f like they
just dumb American
[__] BC does this story and then
turns to whoever in England and says see
yep
after voting ended the village clerk
sent an image of the final tally to both
candidates am I seeing this right Mr
Bell remembers thinking upon seeing 256
to 256 count a dice roll was one of the
options not a recount the nope the three
member Board of canvassers considered
pulling names from a hat oh my God
darts Dart so so far it's dice pulling
names from a hat are you ready for this
cutting a deck of
cards that is
that is the most wiconsin
[__] is it cards to play uker to our new
board member the Jack of
Spades are you ready for this
drawings drawing STW I can't even draw
that W or flipping a coin were among the
other possibilities but the canvers
ultimately decided a dice roll was the
fairest look the dice roll is going to
represent our County more than anything
else God okay they felt that if you flip
a coin and a calls one side the other
candidate has no option but to take the
other side that's how it always works in
a dice roll they both get to participate
Heidi T is thinking about fairness we're
going to play five deces three rounds
best of unless you clear it all day
Heidi I wouldn't mind if you lost your
other
hand I want a handless Heidi someone's
going to send this podcast to her and
she's going to be so she's going to be
like what I neither candidate my hands
all right you ready for this this is
amazing the hands of Heidi t
hands of heidy TI are rolling in the
white all right neither candidate was
able to attend the role in person oh you
got other stuff to do bus too busy too
busy there's a lot ofu I told you guys
when you set it up I fish I fish on
Wednesdays from 4: to 8 well what about
you Nate can you be there Nate can you
be there I have a lot of things I've got
a lot of mason
jars I'm trying to solve the murder of
my
lot of
Mur inv P tab oh God lot of murders in
this I know that all right here we go
all right neither can I was able to roll
in person so two canvassers rolled in
their stead oh my God you're going to
leave this I don't like this they just
what you do is you unscrew Heidi's hand
you put the dice in the unscrewed hand
so no real hand is touching it okay Mr
zoski watch the odd event via Zoom I
don't know how Zoom works am I on am I
turn your camera and he was muted for
the first 15 minutes OFA get in here am
I on they can hear you over Zoom oh God
Point your laptop at the dice oh I
figured he's driving how many all right
they they do such a might been in a comb
they do such a like loose number but
approximately how many supporters
reached out to Mr zoski after the result
which I'm not going to tell you what the
result was
30 200 what people that are upset or
people that are well I can't give you
why but they reached out to me wait why
can't you they TI it again cuz I want
you to guess who won okay and by how
much 15 people reached out to him I get
your answers in half a dozen half a
dozen six one one one thanks everybody
for saying when he said half a dozen
everybody goes six guys I knew it well
you know half a dozen in one sit and
teres other one regretted that their
teenage daughter was unable to cast a
ballot due to an out of town doctor's
you would be someone wanted to vote who
else think my daughter's going to vote
for can't we out of town the town is so
small they don't have a I got out of
town doctor's appointment uh another K
all day she had to go on to fond loock
that's where her doctor is we mve and
you don't give up on the people who
whates fond loock translate to by the
lake fond I think it's phone in the lake
F fondue Lake years AG someone dropped
their phone in the lake we should name
the town after thisone of the Lake in
Wisconsin they put cheese in their
chocolate fondue all right so um they
said so the other one couldn't get off
work before the polls closed uh but I do
have to believe my opponent received
similar calls Mr zi said in his friendly
Wisconsin accent he also said he all
right well so now you know who lost but
I don't figured this out I checked that
a long time ago yeah he did however note
that how many voters curiously chose not
to select either candidate oh well the
turnout is always I that's what I'm
saying if it's how many people voted and
chose 512 voted I would guess in a town
of 50,000 no no that's 512 cast a vote
for either guy but now there are other
people who voted but chose not to vote
on either one of these guys oh so what
was the non the not the people who know
that curiously chose not to select
either candidate either they didn't know
how to fill out the form
118 200 half a dozen
six guys everyone knows you're not
impressing me when I say half a dozen
you guys
say he did have note that 78 voters
curious L uh I don't get hung up on a
vote here or a vote there still know
just so you know I have no idea who won
yeah just tell us who won no no no well
I'll guess rob zosi it was between zosi
or Nate Nate Bell Mr Bell asked to keep
the dice as a souvenir and a reminder of
life's unpredictability well he lost
that it's too soon now but I hope
someday Rob and I can get together and
have a charity event rolling Dice off
your ass we will best known for being
home to a Marina and a restaurant good
reading J with goats did you you were
homeschooled no yeah I'm just I can't
believe this is what this town is known
for best known for being home to ARA and
goats on a roof restaurant with goats on
its SED roof goats or goats I've been
there guys you've been to this town yes
it's D County okay don't say that like I
know what that is you kind of looks like
this it's this part that goes up into
Lake Michigan on its own little why do
they put goats on the roof it's just a
it's always been that way it's just
goats on a SED roof don't you know
that's what people come to town to see
all right uh the tie I was staring at
the goats and I missed the polling I
drove into the harbor why can't the
goats vote why can't the they live here
one of them knows me all right the tie
is one of the most exciting things to
happen to this town of how many people
there you go now that's half a dozen
half a dozen that's six come on how many
people I I mean I should know Daniel you
better know you better be closest you
know I'll think of how many people don't
come out to vote I'm going to say it's D
County 3,000 people yeah but it's sister
based 3,000 people 4500 4500 what do you
say doz
a town of
1,16 I never would have dreamed we' get
this much attention up here said Miss ta
before we get out of here Story number
two yeah who won the dice rolled what
was the dice roll that what versus what
and who won one single die single I
think it's one die half a dozen so
someone got half a doz I'll do this all
day six versus
what uh versus two six 6 to2 I like that
like 6 to2 what do you say 53 I was
going to say fine [__] it I'll go 41 41
one of you is exactly rightow I'm stand
53 I don't think it's I think I know for
a fact it's me the only cuz I'm
Rob heid Heidi hold on was Heidi T like
publicist from way back
theid you are so t uh it's me you're
right all right so you guys are all
sticking with yourselves get your
answers in because the person who was
correct that the dice roll was 6'2 oh
part one was you
rob it was Rob I told you I was right
beautiful and who won was it Bell or
zoski couldn't care I really couldn't
care less but tell me who you thinki it
was I think was zosi yeah two zosi and a
bell who won the answer is Nate Bell
won
I don't like it this into your act give
us a little give us a little taste of
what we're going to have in seg public
sex sex I love it Rob that's what I came
here for thank you we finally give
that's why I drove to Burbank we finally
give him what he wants Rob Hubble on the
other side of this break it is dumb
people Town don't go
[Music]
anywhere hey guys welcome back to the
show before we get into the final
segment uh Daniel vankirk I hope people
came out and saw I bet they well sold
out wouldn't that be crazy they didn't
no no you're gonna have lots of great
yeah thank you uh I've hopefully said it
already 100 times but thank you
everybody they would have come to see my
special taping in Chicago on 11-11 which
before this dropped and then my hometown
Rochelle where I did a couple shows and
the the the whole first run of the rose
gold tour more dates are being added but
for right now December 14th Austin Cap
City Comedy Club Danel vankirk that game
love it in this last story let's do it
this have some public sex a lot of it
sent in by Beth at love mzu love Mazo
love Mau okay okay
report report just allegedly alleged
people are saying couple had sex at
Cedar Point no Cedar Point the amus park
oh yeah don't they have like some
amazing roller coaster there that
everybody talks
about how much for this ride how tall do
I have to be to get on to this ride how
tall do I have to be to go in the tunnel
huh s sand dusy Ohio two people are oh
that's a bad place for hot water after I
always think that too after their
alleged lewd actions at Cedar Point were
witnessed by
children it is a small world after all
kids this where you from this is where
you came from K look at it and this is
where you're a dad holding his son face
up to it look watch this police were
called to the Giant Wheel just after
8:30 p.m. on
Sunday it was dark also that's a double
where' you do on the
buccaneer on Sunday for a report of two
people having sex they're doing it right
now it was only two yeah it was only two
only two it would have been great if it
was like five you get bored in the line
you get bored in the line odd number any
of you done the High Roller in Vegas no
that the ferris wheel that's behind the
link oh people definitely have sex in
that thing I've done something in Vegas
on the rooftop of it like one of those
like things that shoots you up oh [__]
it like a moonshot or something like on
was that the stratosphere yes it was
[__] on the roof it's the scariest
thing I've
ever aing it's around the peak the
[__] needle of it and it shoots you
[__] straight sh you but you're
already you go out there and you're like
oh I'm on top of a sky this is high yeah
this is already high very windy are you
afraid of heights at all or no I didn't
think I was oh god oh I am I never you
shoot me up in a ride
uh is it are you loose or is it like
attached you're sitting on it and it's
like who they have like a seat belt what
do you mean do they not have seat belts
you know hold on to this strap and
you'll be fine do you know wrap this
around Subway strap slingshot thing in
Atlanta where they like pull the thing
back and they just slingshot people and
there's all these videos of people like
like passing out and then waking up and
still being in
there so this was just they shoot you up
the needle lock into the thing you lock
like we would be all sitting four next
to each
Circle go down your back is to the
needle point there's also a roller
coaster on the goes out and around and
then back what kind of maniac that is I
got an idea Bill what about what if we
put a roller coaster on the top of the
hotel well we should we're not going to
put it near the edge I mean that's
that's put we're going to put it over in
the middle of the roof it's middle of
the roof it's guys we're out of ecstasy
I've done all we can we're putting on
the roof okay so the High Roller Ferris
wheel in Vegas is I think it's like 30
people Max and it you can do a deal
where it's all you can drink for one
rotation it takes like a half hour to go
around people get of course shots shots
it's like a little moving train card
just goes up and around impregnated a
lot of people somebody go get pregnant
tonight police were called to the Giant
Wheel after 8:30 on Sunday for a report
of two people having sex a Miami BG
that's a weird take on where you from
you from Miami Miami yeah just outside
we're going to retire there of the night
life Welcome to
Miami
Miami myv Miamisburg Ohio woman and a
Florida man it's always even in Ohio
doesn't matter where you go allegedly
had sexual relations on one of the parks
ride according to sanduski police report
the Act was reportedly witnessed by two
women and two children so look away at
this point do not cover their eyes cover
their eyes look away baby look away did
you meet that Florida man oh he was
fixing the ride before I got there
exactly when confronted by police the
couple denied they were engaging in
Intercourse I would think if you are if
you have to be asked were you guys
having sex up there and I tell you no
that's the end of this conversation you
can't prove it unless someone has well
they saw you and they hate me what do
you want exactly though if they got
video well then now counter suit yeah
right why are you thinking of your legal
moves in this cuz I've got plans cuz I
like to go on roller coasters in a very
Six Flags so two women two children saw
this they're confronted by cops they
were get the woman claimed she dropped a
pack of cigarettes and when she bent
over to retrieve them the man helped her
that is I help helped her in with he
kept helping her over and over and over
she kept dropping them
she butter fingers those regular
cigarettes no they're more 120s I need
more they're slippery they're
slippery the the female the group of
females thought it was two that's my
group who witnessed the alleged sex act
described what happened to police in
detail slow down the police are like and
then another guy's like I'm going to
need to make a report too say that again
but whisper it whisper the details can
you lick yourp ASMR can you lick do like
ASMR this is one of the most prompted
when you say it look right
don't break eye content oh you looked
away start over you looked away start
over sir you're not even writing on
anything you don't even have writing it
down you don't even have a pen you're
just doing this on your hand I got a pen
okay this is the most prompted sentence
I might have ever I've ever read on this
show one of the children told an officer
she was traumatized by what she
witnessed oh come on that isar you're
old enough to say traumatized go tell
the officer you're traumatized well you
you that is exact exactly when they get
here you tell them you're traumatized
were traumatized I mean get out of
people's business take your K I'm not
saying they weren't but the kid doesn't
know to say that no yeah and if you're
old enough toic then spoke with the
couple again and they eventually
admitted they engaged in sex why would
you admit that because they got they
broke them they broke them is what
happened if your kids are like what's
going on up there you just say they're
sharing a corn dog which is true which
is probably how far off is that
level which is true the two were
arrested for Publican decency and trans
transported to the Erie County jail
because two of the witnesses for minors
they had they were enhanced to first
degree misdemeanor what I I really want
to ask come on come on I really want to
ask Cedar Point is it worth possibly
ruining these two people's life what's
the Cedar Point did it require more than
waiting for them finding them once they
both uh physically actually both ways
physically get off the ferris wheel and
go the [__] you two yeah I get it do
your [__] just make sure kids aren't
like isn't that kind of all that was
needed you guys had enough in your own
lives of been like I just got to go tell
this person if you give so what you do
is you say you kids give us each 20
bucks and then you go to the two kids
who saw it and you say here go buy
yourself some treats like everyone shuts
up don't tell anybody what you saw take
these $20 bills you know it's going to
Ras teach these kids that when it comes
to sexual things they need to know how
to keep a secet also we don't know I
mean we're obviously taking the wrong
side of this
but ran might to P off what these people
were doing we don't know how [__] she
bent over to get the cigarettes and he
yes so maybe one other option he lit her
candle one other option would be hold
them in their in the security room like
all night scare the hell out of him and
be like you know what you like sex so
much you two are having sex all night
get in the closet and do it for 12 hours
and then when you're done you want to
like when you get caught drinking when
you're in high school
finish smoke though go ahead you want
have sex have sex all day you have sex
in front of this whole kindergarten
class I'm bringing in 12 more women and
you're going to have sex with all of
them until you can't anymore as of
Tuesday Morning neither the man nor the
woman is incarcerate incarcerate
incarcerated at the jail there you go
which I hope it's just some Ohio cop on
a smoke break being like now how how old
were the little kidses
do you want to guess how old the couple
was minor half a dozen half a dozen six
I'm going to say they're both 17 no
they're adults I Oh I thought you said
they were minors oh the kids are kids oh
uh 27 27 and 25 okay
512 I want them to be 65 and 56 it would
be great that would be unbelievable the
woman is 32 oh my God the man is 18 the
man is 23 There He Go knew it you should
have led with that yeah that's I closed
with it woman Rob's cradle the
32-year-old grandmother four told the
man that's story there you go story
that's how we do it in dumb people Town
rob you were wonderful Rob H I love dumb
people there's so many dumb people and
the town is just getting bigger we just
want to make it getting bigger it's not
getting any smarter it's not getting
smarter or smaller here's to you making
fun of that on stage many times in the
near future that I would love to thank
you for saying that see I put it out
there and then it it will manif will
manifest uh we love you guys thanks for
uh listening thanks for following thanks
for watching and come see us live and oh
[__] we got to get back to work
bye around make sound
[Music]
there's